big tech firms have sweeping power that
authoritarian dictators once
dreamed of somewhere in a very hot place
nikolai ceausescu
drools in envy tech companies can in
just
seconds censor videos articles news
reports they disappear
like they never existed government has
placed no limits on these powers so
increasingly the censorship is totally
brazen it's out in the open they don't
care
when donald trump jr posted the footage
of doctors challenging
the coronavirus storyline and adding
their own
views on it as they're entitled to as
physicians
twitter suspended his account and then
deleted the tweet
but even that wasn't enough for the
ghouls at cnn
they complained that trump's account
wasn't censored enough
from my understanding in terms of this
twitter
you know restriction of tweeting for don
jr it's like 12 hours and the question
is how many people saw this
and believed this before before action
was taken talk about if you understand
the
politics behind the president's son
tweeting falsehood despite twitter
suspending his his account and
restricting his account it's it's
the cat's out of the bag you can't
change it yeah
listen it's disturbing it makes a
difference
you can argue it costs lives
those of us who've been in this business
for a while never dreamed we'd live to
see
journalists calling for more censorship
but that's where we are
donald trump jr is the author of the new
book liberal privilege it's available
for pre-order we're happy to have him
join us tonight don thanks so much
for coming on so i i just have to ask
you the bluntest possible question with
respect
given the level of censorship imposed
on you and anyone who supports the
incumbent president
does the incumbent have a chance of
getting reelected
well listen i've been saying this for a
long time i wrote my first book about
just this the censorship coming from the
big tech giants from california
from a as homogenous a group as you
could possibly imagine that's for sure
and if they're censoring my account
they're censoring others you know they
have been trying to do this for a while
i've been talking about
the the deep platforming the
demonetization of people that have big
social platforms that are preaching
conservative values because tucker
you have to note this never happens to
someone
saying something that benefits the left
it only hurts conservatives
now when i posted that video i didn't
say well this
is the gospel i said wow this is a must
watch because it seems very contrary
to the narrative that they've been force
feeding us for a little while
now twitter takes me down for that but
twitter has no problem
saying that coronavirus disinformation
spread by the chinese government does
not violate their rules
that's interesting it happens on one way
it was very nice watching the people
from cnn or msnbc because
jake tapper himself a few weeks ago
posted
study finds hydroxychloric when helped
coronavirus patients survive better
now why is jake tapper not spreading
misinformation
but i somehow am and again i'm not a
doctor i didn't claim to be
i just put something out there that
challenged the narrative and because i
have a large platform
i'm canceled you know who else got
thrown off twitter for the same offense
sydney powell who happens to be michael
flynn's attorney
and has been someone who's been sticking
it to the left so
if fake jake at cnn who no one is going
to confuse
as a conservative can put it but not be
censored
not be questioned and certainly not be
grilled by a panel of his peers
on cnn why is it that it's happening to
me and other trump conservatives
and other conservatives in general if i
see
another republican office holder backed
by google in the chamber of commerce
lecture me that it's not really
censorship
because the government isn't doing it
just a monopoly that exists because of
the government
i'm going to go bananas i mean is there
anybody in power
who can step in to defend the basic most
basic right of all of the american
people which is to say what you think is
true
well actually i think josh hawley in the
senate has done a very good job
challenging this
kevin mccarthy in the house has done the
same thing and that's the problem like i
said i've been talking about this thing
for three years
i see what happens to my twitter feed
i'm probably getting
less than half the retweets and i do
enough of this that i know what i'm
going to get before i hit send
they're doing what they can i did a
panel at cpac with josh
and kevin mccarthy about justice they're
aware the real problem is
that the vast majority of conservative
legislators and republicans
have no idea that this issue is even
going on and more importantly
they don't realize that it's probably a
top two or three issue
with their base if you're religious if
you're pro-life
if you're pro second amendment just look
at your analytics and they've gone
through the floor it's just been a
disaster and it's happened
systematically on purpose and it's going
on now for years
they have to wake up so before you go i
just cannot resist getting your view of
this
the attorney general was up on the hill
today for hearings here's congressman
jerry nadler of manhattan
responding to a question about the
violence watch this
i would remind mr jordan mr biggs
and mr johnson to stop violating the
rules of the committee
to stop violating the safety of the
members of the committee
to stop um holding themselves out as
not caring by refusing to wear their
masks
oh different clip but equally equally
nuts
what do you think of that well
listen i mean this is typical democrat
do as i say not as i do
this is the same jerry nadler that
yesterday on tv
was denying that anything's even going
on in portland
as it relates to the violence that is
decimating
democrat-controlled cities now again 19
of the top 20 cities in this country
are democrat run democrat mayors who
appoint democrats
across the board in many cases these
cities have been run by democrats for
over a hundred years
yet magically it's donald trump's fault
it was donald trump's fault when he sent
federal
officers to help and assist the portland
pd
who by the way were under attack every
night for five weeks
prior to those federal officers being
there but
again it's magically donald trump's
fault but that's the problem tucker
the news that's getting disseminated to
the average guy people like you and me
we perhaps do this stuff
all day long we can see through it but
if you're a hard-working man or woman
you're putting food on your table
you're consuming 5-10 minutes of news
and it's that filtered
and it's that bias that is the lens by
which you are getting your news
it's hard to make an accurate opinion
because you're being spoon-fed all these
things
that is their intention and so you wind
up getting a
health lecture from jerry nadler and
nobody laughs
it's it's it's beyond belief donald
trump i mean that would be one of the
great ironies of all time i know
it's it's really it's really
unbelievable it's like
ed gein telling you to go vegan if i
start taking that advice i got bigger
problems
but great great to see you thank you